erinnert euch bestimmt an harry potter
rational video heute kommt halt zwei aus
amerika und wir sind angekommen gesehen
vielleicht das outfit worum's geht es
geht wieder um harry potter hier ganz in
der nähe von unserem hotel ist heute ein
harry potter fan event im flex schon
hier mit gryffindor scheibe und wir uns
gedacht wir wären noch zum event gehen
was allein schon für sich megacool sein
wird aber wir müssen das ganze ein
bisschen auch in dem wir wenn ich du
wäre spielen meisterlich gespielt dass
noch nicht alle des gutes wir sind in
einem anderen land er kann nicht so viel
passieren
das passiert nicht wenn die leute 10 uhr
15 und wir frühstücken hier in so einer
mauer bei takko bremer trinken / ich
habe mir immerhin wasser geholt ilja
subway leute aber dass hier das hier ist
der absolute wahnsinn
das sind meine freiräume
fast 340 2008 helfer und harry potter
deshalb seit 2007 ist lang bestehen
das unerschwinglich machen das ist
anders
aber mein handy place
weil du
und emma in diesem wunderschönen
ambiente würde ich dich bitten zur
ersten wenn ich du wäre challenge diese
packung hot source auf einmal
traust du dich das das ist schon mega
hart alter damit steige ich echt hoch
ein
ja das machen draußen des mega-stars
leute das ist die schärfste holz aus die
haben das ist ja von holz durch die
feier für fahrzeug für diese komische
sirenen im hintergrund die ich hier die
ganze zeit die ganze packung ist die
ganze packung also nicht die verpackung
aber die packen einfach durch wo mein
gott oh mein gott
er macht es wirklich um einen gott had
to nicht so jetzt kommt jetzt können
sich die nein das wusste ich gerne
erstmal hier mountain blythe hinterher
irgendwas kein sofort muss sich jetzt
wirklich
wagner die recommendation von webtrekk
fest
leute ich hab gerade erzählt was ich mit
denen geredet habe und er so ich hätte
die frage sein was ich hier frühstücken
kamen hier im park
vielleicht habe ich das auch ein
bisschen mitleid mit dir bei der
nächsten aufgabe aber ich glaube nicht
wir gehen jetzt erst mal weg von hier
die sehnen nerven zeigen sollten
vertrieben
okay wir sind ja personen finden werden
und embraer lieber du bist jetzt mal
rein und der comic strip dem weg nach
hause zu haben
die stadt viel peinlicher wieder raus
gesamtbild zu sagen sie mir jetzt
erstmal auch mal harry potter auftritt
an
dann ist auch für mich weniger paar
sachen zu machen
ganz normaler tag in amerika erwarte ich
damals das war glaube ich für uns
einfach nicht laufen halt august schüler
verkleidet um gehört wir sind jetzt hier
angekommen
im hintergrund ist die eventlocation wir
gehen mal in relation altrhein
gottseidank bist du hier machst das
desaster hat eine massive ansammlung von
drachen erscheinen lassen
wir brauchen so viel hilfe möglich
drachen
das heißt wir können hier wahrscheinlich
drachen fangen da sind direkt sagte
neyer glaub ich
das ist ein 2 klick klick drauf
indem wir die eier sammeln werden jetzt
in die jeweiligen ursprungsregion
zurückgeschickt und wir schicken jetzt
quasi einen drachen für asien ein für
europa und so weiter und so fort gesamte
community sind das dreiergespann
bestimmt ist dass auch ein chinesischer
feuer bei ich habe gerade beim ersten
versuch damit angefangen
ok dann direkt level up natürlich sitzt
ich bin doch dann müssten aber auch
gleich mal immer gleich mal
weiterspielen weil wir dr
jetzt muss ich die aufgabe gehen oder
nein guckt euch das an orten überall
harry potter fans und das sieht einfach
aus wie in der großen halle so cool
okay wir waren uns eine ganze weile
unterwegs ohne groß zu filmen
ich bin mittlerweile level 11 nicht mehr
ganz so peinlich airways lange willst du
mit einer hand mit der anderen hätten
der kamera ist komplett schwierig die
eine hand wäscht die andere
da ich bin qualifizierten verfahren okay
ich habe ihn also ich habe mittlerweile
echt schon super selbst angefangen ich
noch kein einziges mal gesehen habe in
deutschland aber ihr gebt euch schonmal
hier von diese bühne wurde komplett
umfunktioniert mégane ist das artwork
darauf von den park hier bin ich zu
werden wie ich die zweikämpfe ob du da
mitfahren darf
schnell ja ob du darfst auch mal fahren
attenborough fordern gehören
aber bitte
matthäus wies allerdings auch nicht zu
transport kurz nach bereit
natürlich das recht
das wasser ist so oder ich meine
vielleicht verkaufen wie das sonst kann
man heute so wir können noch trikot noch
zwei nehmen weil ich bin da nicht so
dass ich sage da kommt meine aufgabe war
zu einfach
ich geb dir auch was einfach so nicht
gibt jetzt hast du das wäre gelaufen
[Musik]
sonst es einfach gemacht hast er ist
auch durchgezogen hast
damit hab ich das nicht so wäre würde
ich jetzt viele antworten antworten am
12 man darf da vielleicht nicht drüber
nachdenken das war echt nur ein zwerg
das ksk die zwölf machen wir nochmal als
nächsten jetzt ich dann eigentlich wir
sind aber auch in so einer umgebung und
glaube ich nur leute sind die spaß
verstehen oder sich nicht verkleiden
sich alle kommen alle um das spiel zu
spielen gesagt was immer geht die
irgendeine person sind sagt das ist so
ein schönes leben so schön und wir sind
einfach toll
was ich je in meinem leben gemacht vor
allem ein englisches rum hier
der markt ist doch eine coole idee
eigentlich ja wir sind ja hier wegen
harry potter bereit dazu ist jetzt
irgendeiner kuppen und fragst du warum
sind die hier was machen wir hier auch
noch in das schöne veranstaltung geht
wieder sitzen
juni wird das event is about just hier
mal enorme everyday die fnt etr ist dank
der max roth geworden
ich glaube es war der persönlich
gefärbte unangenehmer als wir ich habe
sie gefragt er war so das erste nicht
geantwortet weil sich dafür was wir von
ihr lassen sie jetzt erst mal seinen
spielen hier noch ein bisschen weiter
wir müssen eigentlich noch die drachen
fangen wir haben schon ein trend fielen
aber eigentlich mehr interessant der
farm berichtet mal öfters mal sowas
machen also jetzt nicht spielen sondern
fremde aus und hat eine coole betten ist
hier war um ein grad später harry potter
gerade kurz polizeiauto gesehen hätten
fehler gemacht wichtige schlawiner
aber wir sind jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen weiter gelaufen ist so riesig
hier
wir sind hier im neuen bereich wo wir
noch gar nicht waren das ist so groß wie
bayern kann man neue sachen fangen okay
leute ich bin wieder in deutschland und
wenn wir uns hier mal ein profilbild
anschauen sehen wir erst mal dass sie
wunderschön wenn auch was ihr euch
eigentlich zeigen will
wenn wir ins register reingehen und
runterscrollen sehen wie ich habe alle
drachen gefangen und alle drachen eier
und dass ihr werden somit perfekt
genutzt deshalb noch mal ein großes
dankeschön an google play dass ich dabei
sein durfte und wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder bis dahin macht's
gut